[Applause]
it
let's say we get rid of fiat currency we
get rid of paper currency how do we do
illegal [ __ ]
how do we buy drugs how do we pay for
[ __ ]
how do we do things that we don't want
people to know about and that is
a real problem because sometimes you
need to do illegal [ __ ] if you're rich
you need a liver you're going to have to
buy a liver from somebody
right you're going to have to do things
under the table you know you want to get
a discount on
someone's car or whatever like that you
can't have it minted onto the blockchain
what happens to that market it's
important to remember that uh in many
cases
the most illegal stuff happens through
the traditional financial system just in
terms of like
you know go look at how much the banks
have been fined for just laundering
money through their banks right so like
[ __ ] epstein yeah i mean it's
basically you just get into this weird
world of like
we're gonna go lock up the drug dealers
on the street corner but then we'll let
you launder like billions of dollars to
our bank like but you're cool whatever
so like people i think are like on to
that game now uh so i think that that
will continue where like you have these
regulated entities that basically put
their stamp of approval like not illegal
not illegal not illegal regardless of
what the currency is
and it'll end up being illegal so like i
think people you know the big
time illegal folks will do that in terms
of like more what i'll call like the
street crime right
whatever that is i want to buy some weed
i'm in a state where it's not legal how
do i pay for that [ __ ] weed
so there's two things one is there's
still a lot of people use cash for that
stuff for obvious reasons right so i
think that
cash is not going to go away tomorrow
for the number of years uh moving
forward like people still use physical
cash to do something but it will go away
eventually it will return to van luen to
buy some ice cream you can't use cash
yes my dad's joke used to be whenever he
would pay for something at a diner was
do you accept cash that was his dad joke
because who wouldn't
accept cash right there are places that
do not
accept cash in his lifetime yeah
what the [ __ ] happens when all these
places stop there's also
uh privacy coins right in terms of like
there's all this like r d
and innovation experimentation around uh
can i basically use a
cryptocurrency asset that isn't able to
be tracked
right can't uh be seen and all stuff
juries out in terms of like will that
stuff persist as a
private focused cryptocurrency as a
standalone
will the technology be ported over and
eventually incorporated into bitcoin
like
i'm not technical enough to know like
what's gonna win what's not gonna win
but like there's a lot of effort around
privacy
in crypto assets uh and it's very
interesting for this exact reason
and then on top of that uh is maybe the
asset itself
isn't necessarily private and have this
privacy technology but the way you use
it could be private
and so there's all sorts of you know
really at this point kind of
experimentation around like well
what if i have bitcoin which technically
isn't private but i could send it
to you in a way or what if i could take
my bitcoin and i could basically put it
in this thing called like a coin joint
which when i put it in there we all put
it in there and then now you don't know
who's and then i take out another one
and then like yo
it's like you know i was running and
then i had a red shirt i ran into a room
with a bunch of other red shirts like
you know you don't know who i am like
see you
so like again some of this technology is
to mask it a bit
some of this technology is gonna end up
being super super valuable and some of
them are going to look back and be like
man that was really stupid idea but like
it's important for all the
experimentation right right so we are
going to be able to solve a problem
i think so i i'm always i'm i'm like a
long-term
optimist and technologist right like
like technologists will figure out
solutions to real world problems over
time because that's the financial
incentive and also it's like the society
incentive yeah and so if people want to
do something and there's not a way to do
it
technologies will figure it out hmm al
one thing so um you explained this
earlier i think i got it
there's one blockchain and then a bunch
of miners that are constantly doing all
the
uh computing and confirming of all the
transactions
what happens you said you're you
invested in like some company that's
able to
send a bitcoin like across the world
like that like
how is there enough time to get
confirmed by 51 percent of these miners
if
it's in one second yeah so uh layer one
is the is like the mining process you
talked about in terms of everyone is
confirming it
that these 10-minute blocks right so go
back to the monopoly example it's like
if i hold up the piece of paper with all
the transactions and we were all like
yup looks good right
whatever uh layer two uh specifically
what strike is using is called the
lightning network
and so very simplistically uh basically
you and i want to transact with each
other we could open up a channel
and i can send you the bitcoin and then
at some point in the future you
basically write it to the blockchain you
say yo i got the bitcoin now and like
you can basically
uh kind of contribute it into the
transactions so you use the layer one
as a a way to um keep security and keep
kind of
provenance but at the same time you have
this fast transactions
so one way to think about it is um and
this is like a really weird way to think
about it
but like um imagine if uh
you were um on a highway and the highway
was backed up or
it was going a little slow and you got
off the highway went on a side road
right there was no traffic and you got
back on the highway
in some like weird way that's similar to
these like layer twos it's like
it's a faster way to transact but like
you can't take the side road all the way
to your destination you got to get back
on the highway
right and so maybe it helps in the short
term but you still got to get back on
but doesn't it kind of [ __ ] up the
system because
now it's like hey you could have gave me
this bitcoin last week
but i just now said that i got it now
it's like you could have did a bunch of
nefarious [ __ ] throughout that
you're going down the rabbit hole so
there's technical solutions to prevent
that from happening
right so the example i'm using is like
super simplistic uh but basically you're
able to do both you're able to keep the
uh kind of integrity of the bitcoin
blockchain and network and
and who owns what in the transactions
but you're able to do it at the second
layer with with these channels
uh you can essentially do it in a faster
cheaper way
right so i always caveat and i'm like
yeah there's like a bunch of like magic
behind the scenes that makes it work and
more technical people can explain it in
great detail but like from a use case
standpoint the second layer allows for
uh it's easier to transm transact back
and forth from a time perspective and a
cost perspective
versus the layer one who is peter schiff
and why does he hate you so much
peter schiff likes me i like peter
schiff too i i think that we both uh
we both recognized that uh you know i'm
batman and he's the villain so
uh you know it sucks to be him but who
is peter peter schiff
uh is actually an incredibly intelligent
guy he uh
is probably one of the best-known gold
bugs in the world
and so peter schiff has this really
unique uh ability to understand the
macro environment what's a gold
bug they're into gold so a bitcoiner
versus a gold bug yeah
right like another another word into
gold in the into bitcoin yeah
so if you think about bug that fiat
[Laughter]
so so if you think about uh peter schiff
peter schiff has this incredible
understanding of the macro environment
and he's
really really been on top of all kinds
of different things that have happened
from what the government response to the
kovid was
he uh became really famous for uh
calling the 2008 financial crisis
some people would argue you know if you
call a bubble every day
eventually there is one like you can't
say you're a genius right but at the
same time
like he did call it whatever no and
yeah so like like i really respect peter
shift in terms of like his understanding
the financial markets and his uh belief
in sound money
now talk that [ __ ] well look we we agree
on all the problems we actually agree on
the solution
that's what just sounded like that we
agree on sound money
about to drop listen give it to him bro
we agree on all the problems in the
system we agree on sound money money's
the solution which camera's on
yeah this one yo peter listen
but you're a dinosaur dog you literally
got this gold it's physical gold ain't
nobody want the shiny rocks they want
the digital asset they want
sound money in a digital form that's why
everyone is selling gold dropping gold
and they're buying bitcoin i love you
but
you got the problems wrong uh right you
got the solution right but you got the
application of the solution wrong maybe
he's just trying to drive the price down
so he can buy the bitcoins
listen here's the funny thing about
peter schiff is his son spencer schiff
came out of nowhere all of a sudden
spencer shift came on twitter like a
year ago
and this dude literally recently said
nah i'm not gonna listen to my dad i'm
not gonna hold any stock i'm gonna sell
everything and he just bought bitcoin
are you saying that you're his dad
no you're gone
what i am saying is it's a smart move
right peter understands he's like look i
gotta keep my reputation intact i'm the
gold bug i'm gonna get my business going
right but yo my son's gonna be wealthier
than me so he's gonna buy all the
bitcoin and then
we're gonna benefit from the bitcoin we
rock hoes y'all rock fellas
i mean i i didn't say it yeah yeah
so peter schiff just stays getting
bodied on twitter is what you're trying
to say but peter schiff likes it because
his attention right and if you're in the
attention economy then hey
like who's talking about i mean you're
not even giving him gold economy anymore
no
you're really talking like you're a
[ __ ] attention i'm gonna give him a
little attention
listen hey it's good bitcoiners love
peter shift because when peter schiff
says stuff it usually means that if you
buy bitcoin then it's going to go up in
values
because wow he paints the bottoms like
he's just like
he'd be real quiet goes from 50 to 60.
he don't say a word then all of a sudden
it goes from 60 to 55 he's like
oh it's going to zero and then next
thing it was like like all right man
whatever
look here's here's what i will say
though he's been right
a lot of times yeah but the thing he's
been wrong about is
gold's down over the last six months
people are saying they don't want gold
bitcoin is up like 500 percent
yeah in the last 12 months bitcoin is up
i think it's like 550 percent
gold is up like 19 that's little boy
numbers compared to bitcoin
how can it go to zero that's the last
thing i want to know how can it go to
zero just so i'm prepared for it when i
go all in and that [ __ ] hits the [ __ ]
bottom
just tell me how it can go to zero so i
know the more i'm here yeah the more
worried i'm gonna be when you do go in
i'll be in brickell looking for you just
screaming
pumps it's down to 45.
i bet the house i'm being serious man
if i go all in i need your address i did
not
dollar cost average i bought it all
right at the time that's all i know how
to do okay i don't buy part of a sneaker
give me the [ __ ] breads i want the
whole thing when you shop at payless you
don't gotta buy that much
if you put your [ __ ] shoe up put your
[ __ ] shoe up right now
i can't believe this guy's talking [ __ ]
look what he's wearing i strategically
placed myself
saying him with his [ __ ] look what
he's wearing
but he was coming at your shirt earlier
i didn't say nothing about that but yeah
because you know this just fly yeah of
course
but this [ __ ] with the feet first of all
put your foot on him it's atoms listen
you're a size eight
you don't talk about speed ever for your
come on you don't want this dog
you don't want these flippers bro so you
got so much room in the back your heels
ain't even touching the back of your
shoes you got clown shoes on it
you got [ __ ] clown shoes on no it's
bitcoin there's room to grow baby
we gotta do this let's go
you